you learn how to work out the areas of a
whole bunch of shapes right at least
four or five could it will help me
remember what is some of the shapes that
we've learnt the area for ya the trapeze
whoa let's go straight for the young
straight for the hot one okay so the
trapezium right what's the area of a
trapezium here a bit visit oh it's a
tricky one
it is a hub what Jordan what here we go
okay yeah okay very good
the trapezium is actually one of the
hardest ones okay so well Doug we went
straight for it you want how about a
simpler shape solution yes the square
thank you okay I'm just gonna start
drawing up cuz you guys know what these
are okay what's the area of a square
what's the formula was a point even Oh
almost yeah kind of the edge it's a
Cyberman yeah this side squared very
good the triangle okay what's our area
of a triangle
oh yeah okay half and we usually say
bases that with but with this fight okay
I like that good we've got three shapes
so far let's have another one
trained each other hand up or were you
gonna answer this question never mind
that's a kid rated rectangle thank you
alright so to make this a little what's
up
error rectangle if it's like you know
this broad its breadth it's like this
one won't explain what's our formula in
it is just like a square except the
squares a special rectangle so the two
sides are the same so here because the
signs are different we just want the
button yeah usually we call it lake
times bread does it matter which ones
which no really cuz because like 5 times
3 and 3 times 5 are the same that's
exactly right
okay did we learn any other shapes any
other shapes
yeah the kites wolf
do we let the cut wait da Tweedy uh the
kind is similar to some of the ones that
here how do we say the formula for ya
will ya this is tricky this is tricky
Daniel do not go okay yep so d1d take
what I did what I did okay almost we do
have that line down the middle
why is that line important it's the what
kind what kind of what kind of um mine
is that starts with the D that's why
it's Dean it's a diagonal right it
divides it in huh okay you know what
diagonal you got the other one money
when you harvest okay was that it that
looks pretty good to me or be sickening
very good and I think this should be our
last one
what was that
area of a parallelogram yes okay V H
that be careful what a B and H yeah
Jordan okay yeah bread's and hi and be
really careful Ryan even put this on
another color and maybe want to go back
to yours right hi has to be
perpendicular it has to be perpendicular
it's not it's not this guy over here
that's not height one of the ways I
remember it is the perpendicular height
it literally looks like an H can you see
that like there's a there's an H there
right so that's that's how I first
remembered
okay the height it has to make that
right angle I'd like to stop the height
it's like leaning over yep
yeah yeah that's right so and that's a
great transition into what we're about
to do if what I do is I cut off like a
slice off a triangle and then just like
move it around what you end up getting
looks all like a rectangle right so that
idea leads us right into this heading
which is copies of shapes please make
that early if you haven't already met
this idea of taking a shape and
considering it as like little parts put
together
that's what composite shapes are
compositions are figures that are made
up of other shapes just like this
parallelogram you can say oh it's like a
it's like a triangle here in other bits
and they're all added together okay
that's what composite means in fact if
you are have any siblings or friends
family friends or anything like that who
are engineers who record materials
they'll often talk about composite
materials which is like when you put
together more than one like metal for
instance and it comes together and make
something else okay save do it composite
shapes you put together multiple shapes
you get something else
so copies of shapes are figures made up
of other shapes okay so all these
formulas that you gave me just now
they're all that area we moved past
preeminent a while ago so to imagine
your area because composite shapes are a
little trickier they're just regular
shapes right we've got a few steps here
and I've got kind of I couldn't make a
proper word out of this but DDC see
hopefully is old enough there are four
steps to working out the area of a
conference of shape and they go along
like this step number one right we
always begin with a diagram in geometry
so you can see what you're looking at
and work with it step one is draw second
step is define as you'd like cut it up
slice it up into different pieces and
I'll show you an example of all these
when you divide that also as you'll see
it a really helpful time to label
what you've got there then our last two
steps are not these they're seized so
then after you divided you calculate
you'll have a whole bunch of different
pieces and you calculate each one and
then the last part you do is you've got
all these pieces now but they're really
one shape right so you combine them back
together and there's a couple of ways to
do that so steps 1 through 4 draw
divides calculate combined